tous les enfants ou une fée marraine qui
veillent sur eux
c'est la petite fée qui est d'ailleurs
ajoute cm king closet
elle voulait grandir un peu trop vite
lui rêve d'explorer des terres inconnues
qui sont ces deux petits vagabond et
qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait de mes enfants
cette histoire est née dit c'est celle
de frères et d'une soeur de petits
aventuriers alice et pilule
je suis panne tu as de l'informel ici
vous êtes chez moi tu dois payer tes
délicate and as tu été voir ton père
comment va-t-il
c'est encore lui le patron pas vrai
[Musique]
les garçons perdus à votre service
les ongles de ta fille sont rangés
jusqu'à l'os
fera de toi une demoiselle
alice j'aime vivre avec nous rosa tu
devras payer sa dette
il me faut plus de temps
comportement de tous
vital n'est ce pas vite éteindre arrêtez
jamais de briller
[Musique]
il se retourne me coucher je veux aider
papa moi aussi
[Applaudissements]
dites moi dit votre opinion ces couacs
on a tous besoin d'un peu plus de
courage par moments
[Musique]
si pas encore le moment de grandir à 10
peter tut
[Musique]